うっうー do
[拍手]
僕には人生で2つ真剣に取り組んだものがあります
その一つは
音楽です
でも今日はもう一つの
真剣に取り組んだもののお話をさせてください
10年前の夏
僕は突然頭が痛くなって病院に行きました
すぐに忠誠骨髄性白血病と診断され入院
程なくして
抗がん剤治療が始まっていきました
白血病の治療は
何の心構えもないまま
突然に始まっていきます
そしてこの病気は
僕はそれまで
コツコツと積み上げてきたもの
一瞬で
奪い去ってきました
東京で治療が始まっていきます
今でも悔やまれるのは
妻や
娘に
ちゃんと説明することもなく
この治療に入っていってしまったことです
最初の治療で僕はとんでもない量の抗がん剤を投与されてしまいました
してボクの身体ボロボロになってしまいます
それを見かねた令人と妹たちは福岡に帰ってくることを
勧めてくれました
それからちょうど一月経った
頃に
僕は高校を卒業してから27年間住んだ
東京後にすることにありました
不等価に帰ってきてからも治療は
つずっと続いていきますん
そしていったんは寛解を迎えて退院できたんですが
その半年号
また再発して再び入院することになってしまいました
悪いことは続くものデー
その時
僕はもうこう犯罪が
全く効かない体になってもらったんです
医師からは
緩和ケアを
進められ人生最大の絶望感を味わうことになってしまいました
しかしその時
僕に神風が吹いてくれたんですん
リボンの会という患者の回答の出会いによって
セカンドオピニオンができて
僕は念願だった病院に転院することができたんです
そして降る街の妹から
提供を受けて
骨髄移植に踏み切っていきました車
そしてすぐにイモトの
造血幹細胞は僕に生着してくれたんです
それで僕は治療はもう
終わったんだっ
思ってたんです
でもそれは
大きな大間違いでしたいっ
その子の治療の中で何が一番苦しかったかといえば移植から半年後に発症した
慢性自分 hd という合併症です
僕のたくさんの症状が現れました車
一つはしたが
半分から避けるように
割れてスペック家の中が泡だらけになってしまうというそういう症状です
でもこの症状が2年ほどかけて少しずつですけど
よくなってきましたん
そして2つ目
まったく汗をかけなくなってしまったんです
夏の暑い日に
外に何か出ると僕の対応は一気に39度くらいまで上がっていってしまうんですね
そういうときはどうするかというと
コーラ滴る中でもう物理的に冷やすしかないんです
っつ
汗をかけなくなって
2年目の夏
ここ胸腺というところ
1滴だけ汗が滲んだんです
僕はもっと嬉しかったですね
そしてその翌年
翌年のまだ残暑が残る9月のある日のことです
僕は自宅でから愛ちゃんぽんをつくって
夢中で食べてたんですね
そして気がついたら
顔中からザーっ
ものすごい汗が噴き出していったんです
その瞬間僕は
助かったのかもしれない
ここの中で叫んでました
そして3つ目
この症状が一番嬉しかったんですけど体中の水分が
足元に
どんどん落ちていってしまって
足が二種のように
針上がってもまあまあ
いつも腫れ上がっているんです
寝ている時にはどういう風にするかというと
足をソファに上げて
足元に落ちていた水分
少しでも戻そうと
するんですまぁ全部は全然戻らないんですけど
して立ち仕事なんかするともうまた
元の僕神というかまたどんどん落ちていってしまう
そうなるとまた足を上げて
そういうことを一日中を繰り返してんです
だからそういう人は
働きたくても
働けないんです
そしてこういう人が土の中にはたくさんいるんだってことを部下する時初めて知りまし
た
そして4年が
立った
頃
僕は
また
音楽を仕事に
福岡でできるんじゃないかと考え始めました
まあそれは望みのようなものです
でも体まだ米も寝てたんだ
全然動きません
そんなある日ポストに
協会からの
お知らせが届いてました
そこに何て書いてあってかというと
ゴスペルを一緒に歌いませんかって書いてあったんです
他もすぐに
通い始めてそして歌わせてもらっているうちに少しずつ声が出て行っていっ
そして5年ぶりにピアノを弾かせてもらって
そういうことをしているうちに僕の音楽の間は少しずつ戻って言ったように思います
そしてその後すぐ新しい声もいただいて
音楽レーベルや
音楽の学校
それを立ち上げることが
でできたんです
その時その時にいつも助けてくれる人たちがいました
車
今でも本当に感謝しています
そしてこの病気が
僕にたくさんの気づきや学びを与えてくれたんです
普段は全く意識していないようなこと
例えば
足を変えたり
息をしたり
血液を循環させたりそういうことに比べたら
僕が
4になってまあ苦労してやってたと思っていたことそういうこともまあ
些細なことだったんだなあンっと思うんです
なぜなら僕たちは
生まれたときから
ずーっと大きなものに守られて生きてきたんですから
この病を乗り越えた今この経験は僕の中でここになっています
ところでみなさん
じゅ目を
かなえる時の心構えって知っていますか
僕は辛い時米ち d の最中に
ファイバーアーティストの石田智子さんの
言葉に出会うことができてそのことを教えていただきました
それがこちらです
そしてこの言葉僕の中で
このように
編集されていきましたん
寿命や希望は
確約のないところで未来の自分と約束を課すこと
思えば
凌玖良機と戦った時も
音楽の道を志して言った時も
いつもそうだったように思います
そして母は今でも良く言ってくれるんです
あんた闘病中
いつでも明るかったねって言っ
この言葉も僕の
誇りです
そんなはぁから55年前の超
1月27日に入っ
産んでもらって
今日もまた新しい音楽を僕は作っ
感謝の気持ちで
僕はへ
ここに生きています
貼ります